sous la risée la plage celle de la baie
des cochons soit l'un des échecs les
plus cinglants de l'armée américaine si
on fait exception du vietnam
tout d'abord le contexte souvenez-vous
nous sommes en 1961 au temps de la
guerre froide et le tout nouveau
président des états unis un certain john
fitzgerald kennedy décide d'une invasion
militaire à cuba un an et demi après une
révolution menée par fidel castro très
proche de l'urss
des dizaines de milliers de cubains ont
déjà fui vers les états unis avec
lesquels elle le nouveau pouvoir à la
havane entretient des relations
délicates prédécesseur de kennedy
eisenhower planifie l'opération il rompt
les liens diplomatiques et déclenche un
embargo partiel contre lille d'écart
il y à ce moment là des exilés issue de
la grande bourgeoisie cubaine des alliés
économique des grandes firmes notamment
de la united food à l'époque qui sont
aux etats-unis et dont les propriétés
ont été nationalisées à ce moment là il
ya une réaction en floride de cet exil
et conjointement avec l'administration
américaine
la décision est prise de tenter de
renverser le gouvernement castriste une
conspiration entre le gouvernement
américain et des réfugiés se met alors
en place la brigade
25 06 et former directement par la cia
objectif envoyer mille 400 volontaires
sur l'île et établir une tête de pont
pour installer un gouvernement
provisoire à cuba puis un pouvoir
favorable à washington c'était cousu de
fil blanc évidemment mais il n'était pas
question pour kennedy que les états unis
et une implication officielle dans ce
débarquement
l'opération des vétos matin du 15 avril
1961 par une violation des conventions
internationales
huit bombardiers américains b26 d'école
du nicaragua des avions peint aux
couleurs cubaine pour faire suggéré une
rébellion locale
les 26 parviennent à détruire la moitié
des appareils cubain à la havane et à
santiago le 17 avril soit deux jours
plus tard à une heure du matin le
département commence dans la baie des
cochons à 200 km au sud-est de la
capitale
mais l'opération tourne au désastre
grâce aux appareils militaires épargné
l'avant veille et dissimulé en prévision
sur ordre de fidel castro l'armée
cubaine bloque les trois routes d'accès
à la baie et bombardent la brigade 25,06
cloué sur la plage
s'ensuivent deux jours d'affrontements
un raid aérien toujours avec des faux
bombardier cubain est lancée par kennedy
débarqué entre deux endroits à distance
25 km des hommes envoyés par washington
sont en pleine débâcle
certains fuient dans la jungle d'autres
reprennent la mer dans les embarcations
de fortune au bout de 72 heures en
cercle et est acculée la brigade sera le
bilan une centaine de tués et plus d'un
millier de prisonniers côté américain le
triomphe hautement symbolique et pour le
lider maximo
il s'agit d'une victoire morale sans
équivoque pour fidel castro qui a su
résister aux géants impérialiste avec sa
modeste armés évidemment aucun pays au
monde ne se laissent duper par la
paternité de l'invasion qu'elle est d'y
assume mais accuse la cia de l'avoir
manipulé expliquant au passage la
victoire à des paires par centaines et
la défaite est orpheline la sphère
cimenter définitivement les liens entre
cuba et l'union soviétique -puis la
russie- elle représente aussi la
première défaite militaire américaine
dans un conflit asymétrique un
traumatisme qui ne fut effacée à des
mémoires que par la déroute du vietnam
et qui démontre toute la détermination
idéologique des états unis à l'époque
mais à la baie des cochons
l'oncle sam n'est jamais arrivé à bon
port